[Music]
the facts which i am about to relate
happened to myself some 16 or 18 years
ago
at which time i served her majesty as an
inspector of schools
now the provincial inspector is
perpetually on the move
and i was still young enough to enjoy a
life of constant traveling
there are indeed many less agreeable
ways in which an unbeneficed person
may contrive to scorn delights and live
laborious days
in remote places where strangers are
scarce his annual visit
is an important event and though at the
close of a long day's work
he would sometimes prefer the quiet of a
country in
he generally finds himself the destined
guest of the rector
or the squire it rests with himself to
turn these opportunities to account
if he makes himself pleasant he forms
agreeable friendships
and sees english home life under one of
its most attractive aspects
and sometimes even in these days of
universal commonplaceness
he may have the luck to meet with an
adventure
my first appointment was to a west of
england district
largely peopled with my personal friends
and connections
it was therefore much to my annoyance
that i found myself
after a couple of years of very pleasant
work transferred to what a policeman
would call
a new beat up in the north unfortunately
for me
my new beat a rambling thinly populated
area
of something under 1800 square miles was
three times as large as the old one
and more than proportionately
unmanageable
intersected at right angles by two
ranges of barren hills
and cut off to a large extent from the
main lines of railway
it united about every inconvenience that
a district could possess
the villages lay wide apart often
separated by long tracts of more land
and in place of the well-warmed railway
compartment and the frequent manor house
i now spent half my time in hired
vehicles and lonely country inns
i had been in possession of this
district for some three months or so
and winter was near at hand when i paid
my first visit of inspection to pitt end
an outlying hamlet in the most northerly
corner of my county
just 22 miles from the nearest station
having slept overnight at a place called
drumley and inspected drumley schools in
the morning
i started for pit end with 14 miles of
railway
and 22 of hilly crossroads between
myself and my journey's end
i made of course all the inquiries i
could think of before leaving
but neither the drumley schoolmaster nor
the landlord of the drumley feathers
knew much more of pit end than its name
my predecessor it seemed had been in the
habit of taking pit end from the other
side
the roads though longer being less hilly
that way
that the place boasted some kind of in
was certain but it was an
inn unknown to fame and two mine hosts
of the feathers
be it good or bad however i should have
to put up at it
upon this scant information i started
my 14 miles of railway journey soon
ended
at a place called bramsford road once an
omnibus
conveyed passengers to a dull little
town called bramsford market
here i found a horse and trap to carry
me onto my destination
the horse being a raw boned gray with a
profile like a camel
and the trap a rickety high gig which
had probably done commercial traveling
in the days of its youth
from bramsford market the way lay over a
succession of long hills
rising to a barren high-level plateau
it was a dull raw afternoon of
mid-november
growing duller and more raw as the day
waned and the east wind blew keener
how much further now driver i asked as
we alighted at the foot of a longer and
a stiffer hill
than any we had yet passed over he
turned a straw in his mouth
and grunted something about four or five
miles by the road
and then i learned that by turning off
at a point which he described as
told tallis and taking a certain
footpath across the fields
this distance might be considerably
shortened
i decided therefore to walk the rest of
the way and setting off at a good pace
i soon left driver and trap behind
at the top of the hill i lost sight of
them and coming presently to a little
roadside ruin which i at once recognized
as the old toll house
i found the footpath without difficulty
it led me across a barren slope divided
by stone fences
with here and there a group of shattered
sheds a tall chimney
and a blackened cinder mound marking the
site of a deserted mine
a light fog meanwhile was creeping up
from the east
and the dusk was gathering fast
now to lose one's way in such a place
and at such an hour
would be disagreeable enough and the
footpath
a trodden track already half obliterated
would be indistinguishable in the course
of another 10 minutes
looking anxiously ahead therefore in the
hope of seeing some sign of habitation
i hastened on scaling one stone style
after another
till i all at once found myself skirting
a line of park palings
following these with bare bowels
branching out overhead
and dead leaves rustling underfoot i
came presently to a point where the path
divided
here continuing to skirt the enclosure
and striking off yonder across a space
of open meadow
which should i take by following the
fence
i should be sure to arrive at a lodge
where i could inquire my way to pit end
but then the park might be of any extent
and i might have a long distance to go
before i came to the nearest lodge again
the meadow path
instead of leading to pit end might take
me in a totally opposite direction
but there was no time to be lost in
hesitation so i chose the meadow
the further end of which was lost to
sight in a fleecy bank of fog
up to this moment i had not met a living
soul of whom to ask my way
it was therefore with no little sense of
relief that i saw a man
emerging from the fog and coming along
the path
as we neared each other i advancing
rapidly
he slowly i observed that he dragged the
left
foot limping as he walked it was however
so dark and so misty that not till we
were within half a dozen yards of each
other
could i see that he wore a dark suit and
an anglican felt hat
and looked something like a dissenting
minister
as soon as we were within speaking
distance i addressed him can you tell me
i said if i am right for pit end and how
far i have to go
he came on looking straight before him
taking no notice of my question
apparently not hearing it i beg your
pardon
i said raising my voice but will this
path take me to pit
end and if so he had passed on without
pausing
without looking at me i could almost
have believed without seeing me
i stopped with the words on my lips then
turned to look after
perhaps to follow him but instead of
following
i stood bewildered what had become of
him
and what lad was that going up the path
by which i had just come
that tall lad half running half walking
with a fishing rod over his shoulder
i could have taken my oath that i had
neither met nor passed him
where then had he come from and where
was the man to whom i had spoken not
three seconds ago
and who at his limping pace could not
have made more than a couple of yards in
the time
my stupa faction was such that i stood
quite still
looking after the lad with the fishing
rod till he disappeared in the gloom
under the park palings
was i dreaming darkness meanwhile had
closed in a pace
and dreaming or not dreaming i must push
on or find myself benighted
so i hurried forward turning my back on
the last gleam of daylight
and plunging deeper into the fog at
every step
i was however close upon my journey's
end
the path ended at a turnstile the
turnstile opened upon a steep lane
and at the bottom of the lane down which
i stumbled among stones and ruts
i came in sight of the welcome glare of
a blacksmith's forge
here then was pit end i found my trap
standing at the door of the village inn
the raw boned grey stabled for the night
the landlord watching for my arrival
the greyhound was a hostile ray of
modest pretensions
and i shared its little parlor with a
couple of small farmers
and a young man who informed me that he
traveled in thorly's food for cattle
here i dined wrote my letters chatted a
while with the landlord
and picked up such scraps of local news
as fell in my way
there was it seemed no resident parson
at pit end
the incumbent being a pluralist with
three small livings
the duties of which by the help of a
rotary curet
he discharged in a somewhat easy fashion
pit end as the smallest and furthest off
came in for but one service each sunday
and was almost wholly relegated to the
current
the squire was a more confirmed absentee
than even the vicar
he lived chiefly in paris spending
abroad the wealth of his pit end
coalfields
he happened to be at home just now the
landlord said after five years absence
but he would be off again next week and
another five years might probably elapse
before they should again see him at
blackwater chase
blackwater chase the name was not new to
me
yet i could not remember where i had
heard it when however
my host went on to say that despite his
absenteeism
mr hume was a pleasant gentleman and a
good landlord
and that after all blackwater chase was
a lonesome sort of world end
place for a young man to bury himself in
then i at once remembered phil
wolstenhume of baleal who in his grand
way
had once upon a time given me a general
invitation to the shooting at blackwater
chase
that was 12 years ago when i was reading
hard at wadham
and wollstonhume the idol of a clique to
which i did not belong
was boating betting writing poetry and
giving wine parties at balial
yes i remembered all about him his
handsome face
his luxurious rooms his boyish
prodigality
his utter indolence and the blind faith
of his worshippers
who believed that he had only to pull
himself together in order to carry off
every honor which the university had to
bestow
he did take the new ticket but it was
his first and last achievement
and he left college with the reputation
of having narrowly escaped a plucking
how vividly it all came back upon my
memory
the old college life the college
friendships
the pleasant time that could never come
again it was but 12
years ago yet it seemed like half a
century
and now after these 12 years here were
wolston hume and i
as near neighbors as in our oxford days
i wondered if he was much changed and
whether if changed
it were for the better or the worse had
his generous impulses developed into
sterling virtues
or had his follies hardened in devices
should i let him know where i was and so
judge for myself
nothing would be easier than to pencil a
line upon a card tomorrow morning
and send it up to the big house yet
merely to satisfy a purposeless
curiosity was it worthwhile
to reopen the acquaintanceship thus
musing i sat late over the fire
and by the time i went to bed i'd well
know forgotten my adventure with the man
who vanished so mysteriously
and the boy who seemed to come from
nowhere
next morning finding i had abundant time
at my disposal
i did pencil that line upon a card a
mere line
saying that i believed we had known each
other at oxford and that i should be
inspecting the national schools from 9
till about 11. and then
having dispatched it by one of my
landlord's sons i went off to my work
the day was brilliantly fine the wind
had shifted round to the north
the sun shone clear and cold and the
smoke grimed hamlet
and the gaunt buildings clustered at the
mouths of the coal pits round about
looked as bright as they could look at
any time of the year
the village was built up along hillside
the church and schools being at the top
and the greyhound at the bottom looking
vainly for the lane by which i had come
the night before
i climbed the one rambling street
followed a path that skirted the
churchyard
and found myself at the schools
these with the teacher's dwellings
formed three sides of a quadrangle
the fourth side consisting of an iron
railing and a gate
an inscribed tablet over the main
entrance door recorded how
these school houses were rebuilt by
philip woolstonhume
esquire a.d 18 mr wollston hume sir
is the lord of the manor said a soft
obsequious voice
i turned and found the speaker at my
elbow a square built
sallow man all in black with a bundle of
copy books under his arm
you were the school master i said unable
to remember his name
and puzzled by a vague recollection of
his face
just so sir i conclude i have the honor
of addressing mr fraser
it was a singular face very pallid and
anxious looking
the eyes too had a watchful almost a
startled look in them
which struck me as peculiarly unpleasant
yes i replied still wondering where and
when i had seen him
my name is fraser yours i believe
is is and i put my hand in my pocket for
my examination papers
skeleton ebenezer skelton will you
please to take the boys first sir
the words were commonplace enough but
the man's manner was studiously
disagreeably deferential his very name
being given as it were
under protest as if too insignificant to
be mentioned
i said i would begin with the boys and
so moved on
then for we had stood still till now i
saw that the schoolmaster was
lame in that moment i remembered him
he was the man i met in the fog i met
you yesterday afternoon mr skelton
i said as we went into the school room
yesterday afternoon sir he repeated
you did not seem to observe me i said
carelessly
i spoke to you in fact but you did not
reply to me
but indeed i beg your pardon sir it must
have been someone else
said the school master i did not go out
yesterday afternoon
how could this be anything but a
falsehood i might have been mistaken as
to the man's face
though it was such a singular face and i
had seen it quite plainly
but how could i be mistaken as to his
lameness
besides that curious trailing of the
right foot as if the ankle was broken
was not an ordinary lameness i suppose i
looked incredulous
for he added hastily even if i had not
been preparing the boys for inspection
sir
i should not have gone out yesterday
afternoon it was too damp and foggy
i am obliged to be careful i have a very
delicate chest
my dislike of the man increased with
every word he uttered
i did not ask myself with what motive he
went on heaping lie upon lie
it was enough that to serve his own ends
whatever those ends might be
he did lie with unparalleled audacity
we will proceed to the examination mr
skelton i said contemptuously
he turned if possible a shade paler than
before
bent his head silently and called up the
scholars in their order
i soon found that whatever his
shortcomings as to veracity
mr ebenezer skelton was a capital
schoolmaster
his boys were uncommonly well taught and
as regarded attendance good conduct and
the like
left nothing to be desired when
therefore at the end of the examination
he said he hoped i would recommend the
pit end boys school for the government
grant
i at once ascended and now i thought i
had done with mr skelton
for at all events the space of one year
not so however when i came out from the
girls school
i found him waiting at the door
profusely apologizing he begged leave to
occupy
five minutes of my valuable time he
wished under correction
to suggest a little improvement the boys
he said
were allowed to play in the quadrangle
which was too small
and in various ways inconvenient but
round at the back there was a piece of
wasteland
half an acre of which if enclosed would
admirably answer the purpose
so saying he led the way to the back of
the building and i followed him
to whom does this ground belong i asked
to mr walston hume sir then why not
apply to mr wolston hume
he gave the schools and i dare say he
would be equally willing to give the
ground
i beg your pardon sir mr wolstenhume has
not been over here since his return
and it is quite possible that he may
leave pit end without honoring us with a
visit
i could not take the liberty of writing
to him sir
neither could i in my report suggest
that the government should offer to
purchase a portion of mr walston hume's
land for a playground to schools
of mr walston hume's own building i
replied under other circumstances
i stopped and looked round the school
master repeated my last words
you were saying sir under other
circumstances
i looked round again it seemed to me
that there was someone here
i said some third person not a moment
ago
i beg your pardon sir a third person
i saw his shadow on the ground between
yours and mine
the schools faced due north and we were
standing immediately behind the
buildings with our backs to the sun
the place was bare and open and high and
our shadows
sharply defined lay stretched before our
feet
a shadow he faltered impossible
there was not a bush or a tree within
half a mile
there was not a cloud in the sky there
was nothing
absolutely nothing that could have cast
a shadow
i admitted that it was impossible and
that i must have fancied it
and so we went back to the matter of the
playground
should you see mr waltonhume i said you
are at liberty to say that i thought it
a desirable improvement
i am much obliged to you sir thank you
thank you very much
he said cringing at every word but
but i had hoped that you might perhaps
use her influence look there
i interrupted is that fancy
we were now close under the blank wall
of the boy's school room
on this wall lying to the full sunlight
our shadows
mine and the schoolmasters were
projected and thereto
no longer between his and mine but a
little way apart as if the intruder were
standing back
there as sharply defined as if cast by
limelight on a prepared background
i again distinctly saw though but for a
moment
that third shadow as i spoke as i looked
round
it was gone did you not see it
i asked he shook his head i
i saw nothing he said faintly what was
it
his lips were white he seemed scarcely
able to stand
but you must have seen it i exclaimed it
fell just
there where that bit of ivy grows there
must be some boy hiding
it was a boy's shadow i'm confident
a boy's shadow he echoed looking round
in a wild frightened way
there's no place for a boy to hide
place or no place i said angrily if i
catch him he shall feel the weight of my
cane
i searched backwards and forwards in
every direction the schoolmaster with a
scared face
limping at my heels but rough and
irregular as the ground was
there was not a hole in it big enough to
shelter a rabbit
but what was it i said impatiently
and an illusion begging your pardon sir
an illusion he looked so like a beaten
hound
so frightened so fawning that i felt i
could with lively satisfaction have
transferred the threatened caning to his
own shoulders
but you saw it i said again no sir
upon my honor no sir i saw nothing
nothing whatever
his looks belied his words i felt
positive that he had not only seen the
shadow
but that he knew more about it than he
chose to tell
i was by this time really angry to be
made the object of a boyish trick
and to be hoodwinked by the connivance
of the schoolmaster was too much
it was an insult to myself and my office
i scarcely knew what i said something
short and stern at all events
then having said it i turned my back
upon mr skelton in the schools
and walked rapidly back to the village
as i neared the bottom of the hill
a dog cart drawn by a high-stepping
chestnut
dashed up to the door of the greyhound
and the next moment i was shaking hands
with wolstenhume of baleal
he was as handsome as ever dressed with
the same careless dandism
looking not a day older than when i last
saw him at oxford
he gripped me by both hands vowed that i
was his guest for the next three days
and insisted on carrying me off at once
to blackwater chase
in vain i urged that i had two schools
to inspect tomorrow
10 miles the other side of drumley that
i had a horse and trap waiting
and that my room was ordered at the
feathers wallstonhume laughed away my
objections
my dear fellow he said you will simply
send your horse and trap back with a
message to the feathers
and a couple of telegrams to be
dispatched to the two schools from
drumley station
unforeseen circumstances compel you to
defer those inspections till next week
and with this in his masterful way he
shouted to the landlord to send my
portmanteau up to the manor house
pushed me up before him into the dog
cart gave the chestnut his head
and rattled me off to blackwater chase
it was a gloomy old barrack of a place
standing high in the midst of a somber
deer park
some six or seven miles in circumference
an avenue of oaks now leafless led up to
the house
and a mournful heron haunted tarn in the
loneliest part of the park
gave to the estate its name of
blackwater chase
the place in fact was more like a border
fastness than an english north country
mansion
wallston hume took me through the
picture gallery and reception rooms
after luncheon
and then for a canter around the park
and in the evening we dined at the upper
end of a grado call hung with antlers
and armor
and antiquated weapons of warfare and
sport
now tomorrow said my host as we sat over
our claret in front of a blazing log
fire
tomorrow if we have decent weather you
shall have a day's shooting on the moors
and on friday if you will but be
persuaded to stay a day longer
i will drive you over to broomhead and
give you a run with the duke's hounds
not hunt my dear fellow what nonsense
all our parsons hunt in this part of the
world
by the way have you ever been down a
coal pit no
then a new experience awaits you i'll
take you down car shalt and shaft
and show you the home of the gnomes and
trolls
is car shelton one of your own minds i
asked
all these pits are mine he replied i am
king of hades
and rule the underworld as well as the
upper there is coal everywhere
underlying these moors the whole place
is honeycombed with shafts and galleries
one of our richest seams runs under this
house and there are upwards of 40 men at
work in it a quarter of a mile below our
feet here every day
another leads right away under the park
heaven only knows how far
my father began working it five and 20
years ago and we have gone on working it
ever since
yet it shows no sign of failing you must
be as rich as a prince with a fairy
godmother
he shrugged his shoulders well he said
lightly
i am rich enough to commit what follies
i please and that is saying a good deal
but then to be always squandering money
always rambling about the world
always gratifying the impulse of the
moment is that happiness
i've been trying the experiment for the
last 10 years and with what result
would you like to see he snatched up a
lamp and led the way
through a long suite of unfurnished
rooms the floors of which were piled
high with packing cases of all sizes and
shapes
labeled with the names of various
foreign ports and the addresses of
foreign agents innumerable
what did they contain precious marbles
from italy and greece and asia minor
priceless paintings by old and modern
masters antiquities from the nile the
tigris and the euphrates
enamels from persia porcelain from china
bronzes from japan strange sculptures
from peru
arms mosaics ivories wood carvings
skins tapestries old italian cabinets
painted bride chests etruscan
terracottas
treasures of all countries of all ages
never even unpacked since they crossed
that threshold
which the master's foot had crossed but
twice during the 10 years it had taken
to buy them
should he ever open them ever arrange
them ever enjoy them
perhaps if he became weary of wandering
if he married
if he built a gallery to receive them if
not
well he might found and endow a museum
or leave the things to the nation
what did it matter collecting was like
fox hunting
the pleasure was in the pursuit and
ended with it
we sat up late that first night i can
hardly say conversing
for wolsen hume did the talking while i
willing to be amused
led him on to tell me something of his
wanderings by land and sea
so the time passed in stories of
adventure of perilous peaks ascended
of deserts traversed of unknown ruins
explored
of hair breath escapes from icebergs and
earthquakes and storms
and when at last he flung the end of his
cigar into the fire
and discovered that it was time to go to
bed the clock on the mantle shelf
pointed far on among the small hours of
the morning
next day according to the program made
out for my entertainment
we did some seven hours partridge
shooting on the moors
and the day next following i was to go
down car shalt and shaft before
breakfast
and after breakfast right over to a
place some 15 miles distant
called pict's camp there to see a stone
circle in the ruins of a prehistoric
fort
unused to fieldsports i slept heavily
after those seven hours with the guns
and was slow to wake when wollstonhume's
valet came next morning to my bedside
with a waterproof suit
in which i was to affect my descent into
hades
mr wolstenhume says sir that you had
better not take your bath till you come
back said this gentlemanly vassal
disposing the ungainly garments across
the back of a chair
as artistically as if you were laying
out my best evening suit
and you will be pleased to dress warmly
underneath the waterproofs for it is
very chilly in the mine
i surveyed the garments with reluctance
the morning was frosty
and the prospect of being lowered into
the bowels of the earth
cold fasting and unwashed was anything
but attractive
should i send word that i would rather
not go i hesitated
but while i was hesitating the
gentlemanly valet vanished
and my opportunity was lost grumbling
and shivering i got up
donned the cold and shiny suit and went
downstairs
a murmur of voices met my ear as i drew
near the breakfast room
going in i found some ten or a dozen
stalwart colliers grouped near the door
and walston hume looking somewhat
serious standing with his back to the
fire
look here fraser he said with a short
laugh here's a pleasant piece of news
a fissure has opened in the bed of
blackwater tarn
the lake has disappeared in the night
and the mine is flooded
no car shelton shaft for you today
seven foot of water in juke's seam and
eight in the old north and south
galleries
growled a huge redheaded fellow who
seemed to be the spokesman
and it's the lord's own mercy it
happened at night time or we'd be dead
men
all added another that's true my man
said wollstonhume answering the last
speaker it might have drowned you like
rats in a trap
so we may thank our stars it's no worse
and now
to work with the pumps lucky for us that
we know what to do
and how to do it so saying he dismissed
the men with a good humored nod
and an order for unlimited ale
i listened in blank amazement the tarn
vanished
i could not believe it walston hume
assured me however that it was by no
means a solitary phenomenon
rivers had been known to disappear
before now in mining districts
and sometimes instead of merely cracking
the ground would cave in
burying not merely houses but whole
hamlets in one common ruin
the foundations of such houses were
however generally known to be insecure
long enough before the crash came
and these accidents were not therefore
often followed by loss of life
and now he said lightly you may doff
your fancy costume
for i shall have time this morning for
nothing but business
it is not every day that one loses a
lake and has to pump it up again
breakfast over we went round to the
mouth of the pit and saw the men fixing
the pumps
later on when the work was fairly
entrained we started off across the park
to view the scene of the catastrophe our
way lay far from the house across a
wooded upland
beyond which we followed a broad glade
leading to the tarn
just as we entered this glade wolston
hume rattling on and turning the whole
affair into jest
a tall slender lad with a fishing rod
across his shoulder
came out from one of the side paths to
the right crossed the open at a long
slant
and disappeared among the tree trunks on
the opposite side
i recognized him instantly it was the
boy whom i saw the other day
just after meeting the schoolmaster in
the meadow
if that boy thinks he's going to fish in
your tarn i said
he will find out his mistake what boy
asked woolstonhum looking back that boy
who crossed over yonder a minute ago
yonder in front of us certainly you must
have seen him
not i you did not see him a tall fin boy
in a gray suit
with a fishing rod over his shoulder he
disappeared behind those scotch furs
wollstonehume looked at me with surprise
you were dreaming
he said no living thing not even a
rabbit has crossed our path since we
entered the park gates
i am not in the habit of dreaming with
my eyes open i replied quickly
he laughed and put his arm through mine
eyes are no eyes
he said you are under an illusion this
time
an illusion the very word made use of by
the schoolmaster
what did it mean could i in truth no
longer rely upon the testimony of my
senses
a thousand half-formed apprehensions
flashed across me in a moment
i remembered the illusions of nicolini
the bookseller
and other similar cases of visual
hallucination and i asked myself if i
had suddenly become afflicted in like
manner
by jove this is a queer sight exclaimed
wollstonhume
and then i found that we had emerged
from the glade and were looking down
upon the bed of what yesterday was
blackwater tarn
it was indeed a queer sight an oblong
irregular basin of blackest slime
with here and there a sullen pool and
round the margin and irregular fringe of
bulrushes
at some little distance along the bank
less than a quarter of a mile from where
we were standing
a gaping crowd had gathered all pit end
except the men at the pumps seemed to
have turned out to stare at the bed of
the vanished tarn
hats were pulled off and curtsies
dropped at wollstone hume's approach
he meanwhile came up smiling with a
pleasant word for everyone
well he said are you looking for the
lake my friends you'll have to go down
car shalt and shaft to find it
it's an ugly sight you've come to see
anyhow
tis an ugly sight squire replied a
stalwart blacksmith and a leather apron
but there's something uglier maybe than
the mud over yonder
something uglier than the mud wilson
hume repeated
will you be pleased to stand this way
squire and look straight across at yawn
little tumpa bulrushes
don't you see nothing i see a log of
rotten timber sticking half in and half
out of the mud
said woolston hume and something a long
reed apparently
by jove i believe it's a fishing rod
it is a fish in rod squire said the
blacksmith roughly
and if yon rotten timber isn't an
unburied corpse
may i never strike hammer on anvil again
there was a buzz of acquiescence from
the bystanders
twas an unburied corpse sure enough
nobody doubted it
wollstonhume made a funnel with his
hands and look through it
long and steadfastly it must come out
whatever it is
he said presently five feet of mud do
you say
then here's a sovereign apiece for the
first two fellows who wade through it
and bring that object to land
the blacksmith and another pulled off
their shoes and stockings
turned up their trousers and went in at
once
they were over their ankles at the first
plunge and sounding their way with
sticks
went deeper at every tread as they sank
our excitement rose
presently they were visible from only
the waste upwards
we could see their chests heaving and
the muscular efforts by which each step
was gained
they were yet full 20 yards from the
goal when the mud mounted to their
armpits
a few feet more and only their heads
would remain above the surface
an uneasy movement ran through the crowd
call him back
for god's sake cried a woman's voice
but at this moment having reached a
point where the ground gradually sloped
upwards
they began to rise above the mud as
rapidly as they had sunk into it
and now black with clotted slime they
emerge waist high
now they are within three or four yards
of the spot and now
now there they are they part the reeds
they stoop low above the shapeless
object on which all eyes are turned
they half lift it from its bed of mud
they hesitate
lay it down again decide apparently to
leave it there
and turn their faces shorewards having
come a few paces the blacksmith
remembers the fishing rod
turns back disengages the tangled line
with some difficulty
and brings it over his shoulder they had
not much to tell
standing all mud from head to heel on
dry land again
but that little was conclusive it was
in truth an unburied corpse part of the
trunk only above the surface
they tried to lift it but it had been so
long underwater
and was in so advanced a stage of
decomposition that to bring it to shore
without a shutter was impossible
being cross-questioned they thought from
the slenderness of the form
that it must be the body of a boy
there's the poor chaps rod anyhow said
the blacksmith
laying it gently down upon the turf i
have thus far related events as i
witness them here however my
responsibility ceases
i give the rest of my story at second
hand briefly
as i received it some weeks later in the
following letter
from philip woolstonhume blackwater
chase
december 20th dear fraser
my promised letter has been a long time
on the road but i did not see the use of
writing till i had something definite to
tell you
i think however we have now found out
all that we are ever likely to know
about the tragedy in the tarn
and it seems that but no i will begin at
the beginning
that is to say with the day you left the
chase which was the day following the
discovery of the body
you were but just gone when a police
inspector arrived from drumley
you will remember that i had immediately
sent a man over to the sitting
magistrate
but neither the inspector nor anyone
else could do anything till the remains
were brought to shore
and it took us the best part of a week
to accomplish this difficult operation
we had to sink no end of big stones in
order to make a rough and ready causeway
across the mud
this done the body was brought over
decently upon a shutter
it proved to be the corpse of a boy of
perhaps 14 or 15 years of
age there was a fracture three inches
long at the back of the skull
evidently fatal this might of course
have been an accidental injury
but when the body came to be raised from
where it lay it was found to be pinned
down by a pitchfork
the handle of which had been afterwards
whittled off so as not to show above the
water
a discovery tantamount to evidence of
murder
the features of the victim were
decomposed beyond recognition
but enough of the hair remained to show
that it had been short and sandy
as for the clothing it was a mere mass
of rotten shreds
but on being subjected to some chemical
process
proved to have once been a suit of
lightish gray cloth
a crowd of witnesses came forward at
this stage of the inquiry
for i am now giving you the main facts
as they came out at the coroner's
inquest
to prove that about a year or 13 months
ago skelton the school master had
staying with him a lad
whom he called his nephew and to whom it
was supposed that he was not
particularly kind
this lad was described as tall thin and
sandy haired
he habitually wore a suit corresponding
in color and texture to the shreds of
clothing discovered on the body in the
tarn
and he was much addicted to angling
about the pools and streams
wherever he might have the chance of a
nibble and now one thing led quickly
onto another
our pit end shoemaker identified the
boy's boots as being a pair of his own
making and selling
other witnesses testified to angry
scenes between the uncle and nephew
finally skelton gave himself up to
justice confessed the deed
and was duly committed to drumly jail
for willful murder
and the motive well the motive is the
strangest part of my story
the wretched lad was after all not
skelton's nephew
but skelton's own illegitimate son the
mother was dead
and the boy lived with his maternal
grandmother in a remote part of
cumberland
the old woman was poor and the
schoolmaster made her an annual
allowance for his son's keep in clothing
he had not seen the boy for some years
when he sent forum to come over on a
visit to pitt end
perhaps he was weary of the tax upon his
purse
perhaps as he himself puts it in his
confession
he was disappointed to find the boy if
not actually half-witted
stupid willful and ill-brought up he at
all events
took a dislike to the poor brute which
dislike by and by
developed into positive hatred some
amount of provocation there would seem
to have been
the boy was as backward as a child of
five years old
that skelton put him into the boys
school and could do nothing with him
but he defied discipline had a passion
for fishing
and was continually wandering about the
country with his rod in line
are facts borne out by the independent
testimony of various witnesses
having hidden his fishing tackle he was
in the habit of slipping away at school
hours
and showed himself the more cunning and
obstinate the more he was punished
at last there came a day when skelton
tracked him to the place where his rod
was concealed
and thence across the meadows into the
park and as far as the tarn
his skeleton's account of what followed
is wandering and confused
he owns to having beaten the miserable
lad about the head and arms with a heavy
stick
that he had brought with him for the
purpose but denies that he intended to
murder him
when his son fell insensible and ceased
to breathe
he for the first time realized the force
of the blows he had dealt
he admits that his first impulse was won
not of remorse for the deed
but of fear for his own safety he
dragged the body in among the bulrushes
by the water's edge
and there concealed it as well as he
could at night when the neighbors were
in bed and asleep
he stole out by starlight taking with
him a pitchfork
a coil of rope a couple of old iron bars
and a knife
thus laden he struck out across the moor
and entered the park by a style and
footpath on the stonely
side so making a circuit of between
three and four miles
a rotten old punt used at that time to
be kept on the tarn
he loosed this punt from its moorings
brought it round
hauled in the body and paddled his
ghastly burden out into the middle of
the lake
as far as a certain clump of reeds which
he had noted as a likely spot for his
purpose
here he waited and sunk the corpse and
pinned it down by the neck with his
pitchfork
he then cut away the handle of the fork
hid the fishing rod among the reeds
and believed as murderers always believe
that discovery was impossible
as regarded the pit end folk he simply
gave out that his nephew had gone back
to cumberland
and no one doubted it now however he
says that accident has only anticipated
him
and that he was on the point of
voluntarily confessing his crime
his dreadful secret had of late become
intolerable
he was haunted by an invisible presence
that present sat with him at table
followed him in his walks stood behind
him in the school room
and watched by his bedside he never saw
it
but he felt that it was always there
sometimes he raves of a shadow
on the wall of his cell the jail
authorities are of the opinion that he
is of unsound mind
i have now told you all that there is at
present to tell
the trial will not take place till the
spring arises
in the meanwhile i am off tomorrow to
paris and then sit about 10 days
onto nice where letters will find me at
the hotel des emperors
always dear fraser yours pw
p.s since writing the above i have
received a telegram from drumly to say
that skelton has committed suicide
no particulars given so ends this
strange eventful history
by the way that was a curious illusion
of yours the other day
when we were crossing the park and i
have thought of it many times
was it an illusion that is the question
i indeed that is the question and it is
a question which i have never yet been
able to answer
certain things i undoubtedly saw with my
mind's eye perhaps
and as i saw them i have described them
withholding nothing
adding nothing explaining nothing let
those solve the mystery who can
for myself i bet echo wolston hume's
question
was it an illusion
you